contre les repas sans viande à la
cantine moi très simplement parce que je
trouve que une minorité n'a pas à
imposer à une majorité sûr qu'on doit
manger que ce soit des minorités la
minorité c'est à dire la raison pour
laquelle on dit que premièrement la
raison sanitaire je ne trouve pas
justifiée deuxièmement alors appel
jusqu'à raisons sanitaires
le maire sait que ça va plus vite voilà
le maire dit que c'est un service plus
vite et que partant de covin et bien ça
limite les la propagation de l'épidémie
exact c'est le motif officiel le motif
officiel nos motifs officieux c'est que
de toutes les façons il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui n'ont pas envie de manger
de la viande pour plusieurs raisons des
régions les raisons religieuses
soyons clairs sur yon front disons le
tout de suite des régions c'est comment
dirais-je pour la santé c'est à dire
écolo et que ce soit des régions
religieuse aux écolos premièrement il
faudrait que le maire s'oppose le dia
clairement et deuxièmement une minorité
ne peut pas imposer à la majorité moi je
serais pour un équilibre pourquoi pas si
tu ne peux pas manger de la viande
hachée un menu sans viande
mais si tu veux manger de la viande tue
un menu avec viande mois ce qui m'embête
c'est imposer quand une minorité imposé
à une majorité quelle qu'elle soit je
trouve que là on commence à basculer
alors soyons clair vous ne croyez pas la
version officielle ah non j'ai pas du
tout récent entretien d'autant plus que
j'ai trouvé un article de l'express en
2010 où il y avait exactement le même
problème
et c'était pas du tout cette version là
c'était une des religieux qui demandait
justement à ne pas avoir de la viande
dans la cantine ça peut sont donc on
voulait que le débat dégénère tout chez
christie's en attend pas la 30e minute
tomber ne pas faire on va pas fait à des
hypocrites on va parler franchement
accord c'est ce à l'origine après soyons
public il est minorités religieuses aux
minorités idéologique
ben voilà les annales et 2 mais ce sont
deux minorités c'est ça le problème
et l'idée c'est pas qu' il ne peut pas
être entendus pour moi on peut entendre
tout le monde on peut entendre la
volonté de ne plus manger de la viande
on peut entendre la volonté de ne pas
manger de ne pas manger de la viande en
revanche ne l'imposent ont pas aux
autres c'est la seule chose ne
l'imposent ont pas trouvé un équilibre
ce qu'ils veulent ils en ont pour leur
argent
et c'est qu'ils veulent pas ils ont beau
pour l'argent pourquoi pas ça sert
candeur frémissait en vous entendant
pourquoi oui l'engagé comme après ses
critiques guy rappelle la vraie raison
qui a conduit
c'est le maire de lyon a proposé de ne
pas avoir des menus sans viande parce
qu'ils vont on peut ne pas le croire non
on n'est pas obligé de partir du
principe qu'il demande nécessairement je
pense que c'est non mais c'est juste
l'histoire
deuxième élément il a quand même la vie
la crème assumer le fait que même après
la période sanitaires il voudrait
réduire pas interdire réduire la part de
la viande en eux des repas qui sont
fournis aux enfants dans les cantines
donc oui effectivement il va sur ce
terrain là qu'une alimentation sur
carnet masque en fait sur le long terme
tout au long du xxème siècle on a mangé
de plus en plus de viande ni quand ni
comment c'est pas forcément équilibré il
ya 50 ans entend mangez pas autant
demander donc moi à titre personnel je
mange de l'aviron mais j'en mange moins
qu'avant parce qu'on voit aussi les
derricks y sont liées à l'élevage des
animaux aux abattoirs et à plein de
choses et que les enfants peuvent aussi
avoir une alimentation plus variée dans
les cahiers pas obligatoire de manger de
la viande à tous les repas et je vous
que le maire de lyon a raison de mettre
ce sujet sur la table là soyons d'accord
ayant bien d'accord il ya obligation de
ne pas en manger du conte à ces noms à à
court terme pour les reer la situation
actuelle dans la à court terme pour des
raisons sanitaires
il n'y a plus du tout pour des raisons
sanitaires où il n'explique que ça
nécessite plus on me dira de travail
d'échangés que sera de faire de cet
accord mais pourquoi il a dit ça n'est
pas obligé de considérer qu'il ment
nécessaire enfin moi je suis mal sa
place en table basse laissant filer à
kaspar à quoi vous parler autant voulait
le suis pas je suis pas sûr série knock
you lie à et après il a dit que passer
de cette crise sanitaire il voulait pas
interdire la viande mais si vous voulez
on réduire la part et ça je pense que
c'est une bonne position équilibrée que
christine kelly a précisé d'accord je
vais donner la parole à benoît biteau
dans un exploitant qui vous êtes mais
j'aurais juste pour que c'est que
grégory doucet a déjà un petit massif
série des call au oui non mais comme
certains écolos il a pris les positions
un peu étrange lui c'était le tour de
france qui trouvait à l'assistanat voir
non mais simplement c'est quand ça vient
d'un maire écolo maintenant on tend un
peu leur et parce que ils font un début
de mandat qui est un peu curieux et ceci
dès des actifs qu'un petit maçon on peut
ne pas être d'accord on peut
pas d'heure des enfants mais d'accord on
ne peut pas être d'accord la libre c'est
les enfants peuvent aussi manger moins
de viande ça va pas les traumatiser ne
s'agit pas d'interdire s'il vous plaît
c'est la [ __ ] ok paysans agronome
députés écologistes au parlement
européen et vous pourtant vous êtes pour
oui je suis pour parce que contrairement
à l'or je n'ai pas le rôle et romain
s'en vient j'ai pas retenu le nom de
delà de la chroniqueuse mai mais
contrairement à ce qu'elle dit à une
vraie raison sanitaire aller facile à
expliquer c'est un très beau m'expliquer
en 2010
faut qu'on m'explique en 2010 quel était
le motif sanitaire qui est convoqué pour
donc il y avait il ya aucune analogie
possible quand on parle de minorité
majorité faut rappeler quand même qu' il
ya une consultation des parents d'élèves
pour savoir comment est-ce qu'on on
organiser les repas dans un contexte
sanitaire contre un qui faisait qu'on
avait besoin d'espacé
les passages dans la cantine pour
respecter les gestes barrières et que
donc sur un patenté celui le temps du
repas il fallait passer avec les règles
sanitaires
toujours le même nombre d'élèves donc la
question qui s'est posée aux parents
d'élèves c'est est ce qu'on leur sert un
repas froid de type pique nique ou
est-ce qu'on pose un un repas chaud donc
il a été choisi le repas chauds et sur
le repas chaud la seule solution
possible
c'était de retirer la viande de manière
à ce que ce repas unique puisse
permettre de satisfaire la majorité
c'est ça la démocratie la majorité des
attentes les baignoires et à dire que
d'une journée
j'entends je vous dit on après ce sera
la bienvenue en quoi en retirant la
viande et on mettra les gants et ai été
très clair il disait
majoritairement le problème de la viande
il ya des gens qui veulent pas en manger
il ya des gens qui veulent pas manger de
tel ou tel type de viande et le c est le
plus petit dénominateur commun ce qui
faisait adhésion pour l'année en passant
vient d'ouvrir et nerveux
vous venez de dire dans le dans le dans
le sondage il y avait donc des raisons
religieuses les enfants aux prises en
otage voilà c'est ça mais vous trouvez
pas ça bizarre parce que sans être
suspicieux on se dit c'est quand même
étrange que la raison sanitaire
correspondance avec le le problème il
est par nature il est que le sondage les
gens ils répondent que ce qu'ils veulent
on tient pas la main des gens même si on
intègre pas cet argument là la majorité
des familles étaient pour le repas sans
viande parce que c'est le repas sans
viande qui permet de servir un plat
chaud qui convient à la plus grande
majorité des élèves accord donc c'est ça
la vraie question de grégory douce et et
je conclue juste sur une chose c'est que
grégory douce et a pris cette décision
sur fond de crise sanitaire et il s'est
engagé à remettre de la viande déclaré
sanitaires seraient plus l'arrêt
accueille quant à la moins qu'avant
j'étais cycliste de très haut niveau
j'ai pas adhérer à la position de
grégory douce et sur le tour de france
mais là sur ce sujet là je ne soutiens
grégory d'accord lareau